algo así como
el interior 4
[Música]
es una lengua única en el mundo
compuesta por 112 sonidos distintos y 45
chasquidos guays aunque también tiene
eso
esta mujer es la última persona que lo
habla con fluidez
katrina desciende de un pueblo nómada
los suns unos de los primeros habitantes
de sudáfrica aquí en una reconstrucción
filmada hace unos años
durante la colonización de sudáfrica los
suns fueron expulsados de sus tierras y
se asentaron en townships cerca de las
grandes ciudades
aquí es donde katrina vive ahora con sus
hijos y nietos 15 en total
todos hablan afrikaans la lengua
impuesta por los colonos holandeses
me prohibieron hablar mi lengua donde
trabajaba
era muy infeliz pero ya está hecho no se
puede volver al pasado
durante docenas de años katrina dejó de
hablar su lengua y no se la transmitió a
sus hijos
pero recientemente empezó a enseñárselo
a su nieta claudia
y juntas incluso crearon una pequeña
escuela frente a su casa
los niños de la zona pueden venir aquí
todas las tardes para aprender esta
lengua olvidada
el burro está cansado
y la labor que no es para nada fácil
brabo buena pronunciación
el dominio de los chasquidos en
particular requiere mucha paciencia
el road magnet lo mejor que se puede
hacer es practicar trae un está se debe
ser perseverante
desmarets este es el beso de gato
marí
thaksin
recientemente con la ayuda de
investigadores también completaron un
manual de su vocabulario el primero en
su historia en un intento para evitar la
total desaparición de la lengua que es
un chasquido este es otro este es otro
mi sueño es ver la lengua de mi abuela
en las universidades en las escuelas en
la radio en la televisión es una lengua
antigua pero podemos hacerla moderna
podemos traerla a la vida moderna
es una lucha que ha impresionado a los
expertos en lenguas
como este antropólogo de un museo cerca
de ciudad del cabo
a menudo nos encontramos que la gente
que pierde su lengua ancestral pierde
esa conexión con su cultura y con su
patrimonio y casi con su historia es muy
importante mantenerla si es increíble
haber visto el ejemplo de katrina
en el mundo se siguen hablando 6.500
lenguas y dialectos
pero 25 desaparecen cada año y con ellos
una parte del patrimonio de la humanidad
hola